>>Reto Meier: Good afternoon and welcome to
this Friday's app clinic.
My name's Reto Meier, I'm joined by Ian Ni-Lewis
and our senior executive producer, Alex Lucas.
On the engineering panel we have Daniel Pham,
our NFL expert, and today we're gonna be looking
at football apps.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now, if you're watching us
live, first, thanks for sticking through the
completely screwed up intro that engineer
Daniel has provided us because he's usually
great but not today.
And second, if you have any questions for
us or any comments you wanna make during the
show, engineer Alex, I'm sorry, producer,
senior vice executive producer Alex is standing
by on the YouTube live stream.
So he's actually watching the comments as
they go by, he's checking to make sure that
we're not, you know, going all fuzzy or muted
or, you know, distorted but at the same time
he can watch your comments and pass them along
to us if you say anything interesting.
>>Reto Meier: So I'm really excited today
that you guys decided to do football.
Football season is in full swing so, I've
been away from Australia for awhile so I wanted
to kick off and find out exactly how the football
teams are doing.
I've got this app here, Aussie Rules Live
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Nice.
>>Reto Meier: which is really good.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: See when you said Aussie Rules
Live, I thought this was gonna be a Black
Sabbath concert.
>>Reto Meier: Interesting.
Yes, no.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So this is--
>>Reto Meier: If you switch to the phone app
and the tablet for yourself.
Slick.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Nice.
>>Reto Meier: Excellent.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah that's not really what
we had in mind.
>>Reto Meier: No, this is pretty good.
I mean, it's got some sort of iphoney styling
here and we have kind of the action bar but
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's not exactly football.
It has something about Australia in it.
>>Reto Meier: Well, yeah, Australian football.
That's what you guys are talking about, right?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah that's the thing, any
sport that can be abbreviated to something
that sounds like you put it on a baby when
they go to sleep
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: It's not working for you?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: No.
>>Reto Meier: Oh okay, sorry, it's an easy
mistake to make, right?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: I'm from the west coast of Australia
so football.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, the west coast, that explains
the whole thing.
>>Reto Meier: It does, it does.
Okay, we're not talking about Aussie Rules
so, obviously, I thought this through.
So, I've got this rugby app which is great.
It works, it's not quite as nice of display,
we don't have the action bar here we've kind
of got the old school tabs.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, not really getting it.
>>Reto Meier: No?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Who?
The slippers?
The blues?
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, yeah, [cannot understand],
yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: The hurricanes?
>>Reto Meier: Uh, possibly.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I'm, this isn't working
for me either.
>>Reto Meier: No?
That's
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Daniel, are you feeling it?
>>Daniel Pham: I have no idea what Reto is
talking about.
>>Reto Meier: Okay, we're not talking about
Aussie Rules or Rugby.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Who do you prefer War or Woofer
in the alliance stadium mat?
You know, I'm glad to know it's not just in
America that we totally sell out.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: our stadiums
>>Reto Meier: Oh, no.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Try again foreign boy.
>>Reto Meier: Okay, so I've made a common
mistake here.
I assumed that when you guys said you were
talking football that you meant this because,
obviously, what a lot of people think of as
football you call soccer but I did think this
through so I have some other football apps.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: See I knew you were gonna
try this.
>>Reto Meier: What's that Ian?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I knew you were gonna try
to pull in that whole rest of the world football
thing.
>>Reto Meier: Well we have a lot of viewers.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And I know exactly why because
you know that our main, our primary audience
is in Austria.
>>Reto Meier: This is true.
We have a lot of Austrian viewers.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yep.
>>Reto Meier: Thanks for tuning in.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Shout out to you guys.
>>Reto Meier: So I don't know if we've got
the Austrian league here.
I should go through cause I'm sup- well, I
think that's the Austrian flag.
So there we go, so we can see, we can drill
in.
The actual app itself, again, we've kind of
got this pseudo action bar with the refresh
button which I know you're not a fan of, back
button which really should be--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know what?
You know what?
I give up, fine.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We're not doing your Aussie
thing.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But I get it, okay?
>>Reto Meier: Okay.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We've go, we've got enough
non US audience here that, probably because
every programmer in the US, except for you
and me, has been laid off.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Fine, we'll do them.
I was excited; I was excited because the NFL
is starting their season.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, the NFL.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
[Laughs]
>>Reto Meier: Oh is that
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know the NFL.
>>Reto Meier: Is the "F" for football?
I didn't realize that
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It is.
>>Reto Meier: You guys had a kicking game
that you were proud of.
Oh, that's great.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's not just kicking, actually.
There's all sorts of interaction between feet
and hands and--
>>Reto Meier: Balls.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So let's go ahead and take
a look at a few apps from the NFL
>>Reto Meier: Okay, let's have a look.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: from the American football
>>Reto Meier: It'll be an education.
All I know about American football is from
Friday Night Lights so it should be an education.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, well they play high
school rules there don't they?
>>Reto Meier: Well they were in high school
so I would assume so.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well let's get ready for the
NFL season.
I'm gonna crack open an American beer.
>>Reto Meier: Interesting.
Don't we need a, like a tailgate?
Maybe a grill, is there a grill around here
somewhere?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: No but I've already spilled
beer on the table so I think we're off to
an excellent start.
>>Reto Meier: I think we're off to a good
start.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright.
>>Reto Meier: So what do you wanna start with?
You guys are the NFL experts.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well, let's actually start
with one of the NFL apps.
>>Reto Meier: Okay.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That one?
So, if we go over to the tablet, one of the,
one of the apps that I thought was really
impressive is NFL Preseason Live.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now, the thing about NFL Preseason
Live, it has really terrible reviews and there's
was one really good reason for that and it's
that on ICS and up, actually on Honeycomb
and up, the video playback was really, really
sketchy.
Now, sadly this is because previous to Honeycomb
they were actually using their own playback
engine for their HTV live streaming and post
Honeycomb they went ahead and, well there
you go, post Honeycomb they went ahead and
used out playback engine and it turns out
that ours was a little less resilient than
theirs.
They had some streams that had a little bit
of, okay so I think we're gonna need to switch
to the regular camera here because as soon
as we start playing video it switches over
to full screen mode.
>>Reto Meier: You may wanna zoom out just
a touch, I think.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So what they've done is they
had a few streams where the audio part of
it was malformed and it crashed our decoder
and then it was unable to recover.
So once we got rid of that problem everything
was okay.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I like the app.
There's a few problems with it but the basic
concept is really cool.
So, what you're getting here is start a, we
start a game, you can look at any game that's
already played or I believe you can look at
them live but I haven't had the time to check
it out live myself.
When you-- now here's what's gonna happen
and this is the problem that we've seen in
the past is we actually can't get the video
now because the, that one stream crashed it.
>>Reto Meier: Gotcha.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I kind of know
>>Reto Meier: Once you have the crash then
you're, yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, let's go ahead and just
pretend the video is playing.
>>Reto Meier: That's probably best that it's
not there
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's probably best, yeah.
>>Reto Meier: cause the man might get--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know, we should have just
said that to begin with.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We should've been like, "Oh
yeah, we blacked it out because of the man
cause we're that good."
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
It's actually well done.
We can actually see the video here but I believe
it's not coming across cause Daniel is blacking
it out.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: real time.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yes, exactly.
Good save.
Okay, so what you can see, though, is they've
actually got a whole list of all the plays
that happened in the game.
It's a little; it took a while to figure it
out.
>>Reto Meier: Wow.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But the orange circles basically
means there was some ball movement and then
you get, I think a triangle for a turnover,
you get, if it's blue it means they scored.
So like, for instance, here's the--
>>Reto Meier: There you are.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: 20 yard field goal.
>>Reto Meier: 20 yard field goal.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And what's really cool about
it is you can go down here and see where the
plays are that you wanna look at and then
if you click over here then it'll actually
bring that up on the video.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it'll take you right
to it.
>>Reto Meier: So basically like an index.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: For every play.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah and it works really well.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: The main problem I have with
it is first, it's a little bit cryptic like
there's nothing that tells you what the little
markings mean, etcetera.
Second, if you can see the difference between
my quite normally sized finger and the touch
target, it is a little on the small side.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, it's definitely not following
that 48 pixel rhythm which I'm kind of expecting.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
Well, 48 DP.
>>Reto Meier: 48 DP I should say.
As well, I'm, does clicking anywhere do the
shortcut or do you have to specifically hit
the?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Actually, clicking anywhere
does as long as it has the little triangle.
That means that there's an index.
Now, I would probably prefer a different icon
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: because we've always thought
that when you have a triangle pointing one
way that means that you're either going to
slide and see content that's hidden over on
the right or maybe the triangle's gonna turn
and you're gonna get something beneath it.
There's pretty well accepted user interface
guidelines that users are gonna have expectations
around, where in this case, all it does is
click and put the video on a different place,
it's not even always the right place to be
perfectly honest but it's always close.
>>Reto Meier: It feels like a pretty obvious
icon to use instead would be, in fact, a video
camera or something like that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Sure.
Absolutely.
You know, or some sort of a bookmark icon
would be fine too.
>>Reto Meier: That could work as well.
Just some sort of indicator cause clicking
here you kind of assume that it's gonna be
a drill down and you get more detail on that
particular play.
The video is probably better but it's sort
of not clear.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: The other thing that I would
love to have is some sort of sorting ability.
You can sort, for instance, on scores but
you'll notice that that removes the bookmarking
functionality.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, yeah absolutely.
That's a shame cause that's kind of gonna
be the highlight that you look for.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
For me, I'm all about the passing game so
I'd really just like to see all the big passes.
>>Reto Meier: Sure, that makes sense.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I found myself, literally
for this game, sort of scrolling through and
looking for like a yardage number, oh 15 yards,
maybe I wanna see that.
>>Reto Meier: It seems like there's a lot
of information going on on this screen but
what really isn't clear is exactly, like you
have to read everything in order to see anything.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know what it reminds me
of?
It reminds me of trying to read the scrolling
output from like a role playing game or something,
you remember those old school stuff?
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It actually reminds some, I'm a cricket fan,
I'm gonna wanna review cricket apps at some
point, but it's the same sort of thing where
you have sort of constant, you know, six balls
and over it's just constant, whatever happened.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now, I just wanna cut in,
Reto, and just--
>>Reto Meier: Please do.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: just remind the viewers that
you have the power on this show.
We do listen to reader comments or viewer
comments; we do abide, in general, by viewer
votes when we're reviewing apps so you have
the power to stop the cricket madness.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Or, indeed, to force the cricket
madness if that is your inclination.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
>>Reto Meier: So anyways, the point is that
a lot of people follow the cricket just by
watching the live commentary so they've kind
of optimized that process of having the most
important thing first.
So the number of runs scored off each particular
ball is the first thing you see or if the
person was out then that's the first thing
you see and I'd like to see the same thing
here.
The distance passed seems like that would
be the most important thing on a completed
play.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: Or, in fact, scoring seems like
it should be something that should be fairly
obvious.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
But you can see that it feels like they actually
haven't taken a huge amount of care here because
if you look at this it actually repeats some
information.
This is the time on the clock and then time
on the clock is the first thing you see here
as well.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So I think this feels like
they're just pulling it off their news feed
of some kind.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: At the same time, although,
it could be presented in a slightly nicer
format, this is some great information.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's a really useful app.
>>Reto Meier: Just a presentation thing at
this point.
I mean, the app itself is obviously hugely
useful to any sports fan.
It's really just a case here of trying to,
you need to make this text bigger, you need
to make the touch targets bigger and expand
the text cause I think all of you guys watching
can see that you'd be pretty lucky if you
can read any of this from the camera.
And, in fact, as soon as you sort of sit back
from it you're checking to make sure your
prescription is still valid.
It's small.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right and on a Nexus 7 it's
even less useful.
>>Reto Meier: I can imagine.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's very, very difficult
to use.
>>Reto Meier: This is a pretty big tablet
as tablets go these days.
So you really wanna have that bigger and,
in fact, there's no need.
Like, what they've kind of optimized here
for is to have as many plays on screen at
a time and that's probably not what you wanna
optimize for, right?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I think you're right.
I think that rather than seeing a huge number
of plays where I have to carefully read each
one, I'd rather have the information presented
so that I can scan it so quickly that flicking
this up and down will actually be useful.
>>Reto Meier: Yes, absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So if I see, and you can see
they've done a little bit like I can flick
this up and down and when I see this little
blue-ish green color go by, even if it's moving
very fast, I can see that because it stands
out from the rest of everything.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So bravo on that count.
Now, take that idea and extend it out to the
rest of this particular UI and I think you've
got a real winner.
>>Reto Meier: And, in fact, what I would say
is you've actually got the right idea here.
So if we look over here on this side you can
actually see that they've got this rich and
large touch targets.
That's probably about the size you want and
the same way that they've got their sort of
background bleed image, that'd be kind of
cool even having this done here, right?
So you could have the same UI element over
on this side with a beak, you know, rather
than having a sort of small logo, you have
that background effect, bigger text, more
dramatic, you know, view.
Particularly here cause we've got light gray
on slightly darker gray, if you're supposed
to be able to read it make it stand out, put
it in bold, make it bright white against black,
you know, whatever you like.
But I would say something like this over on
this side so you can actually read it.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, over on the left is
great isn't it?
>>Reto Meier: That looks fantastic.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it's just beautiful.
I'm really impressed.
So, I think, I just wanna say one more thing
about this app and that's about the top of
the app.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Go ahead.
>>Reto Meier: No, no, please.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, no I was just feeding
you lines.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I was feeding them and you're
running.
>>Reto Meier: I like this, yeah.
I need a blocker.
So we've kind of got this, it's not an action
bar it's a title bar and it's kind of all
wrong, right?
I mean, this is a--
>>Daniel Pham: Hang out.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh man, all of a sudden I'm
being Dan Galpin.
Yeah, I gotta watch the content monitor.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: So, this at the top and even
here where you're looking at the sort of almost
tabs, turn them into actual tabs so that I
stop having to do scare quotes and this title
bar should really be an action bar.
So things like settings, if I hit this, so,
yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: I don't even know where to start.
So this should all be in an overflow menu
and it shouldn't be this weird dropdown popup
thing it should just be a standard menu affordance.
Now, as far as I know, this is a tablet app,
an app for tablets only, is that right?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Okay, so you don't actually
have an excuse not to use the action bar because
you don't have to worry about backwards compatibility,
you don't have to worry about how your menu
is gonna work on other devices, you just make
it an action bar.
So this, all of this stuff, it's fair enough
to have, to put this in settings but settings
should kind of always be in the overflow menu.
I'm not quite sure what the question mark
is gonna do.
Oh, hello.
So it's like on screen tips.
That's actually not bad.
I don't know that I'd make it a primary action,
again, I'd probably stick that into an overflow
menu and maybe display this the first time
the app came up.
I don't know
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I will say that, in general,
if you find that it's necessary to show something
like this it is probably a good clue telling
you that you're--
>>Reto Meier: A little too complex.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: not doing a good UI.
>>Reto Meier: Things should be as intuitive
as possible.
You know, you shouldn't have to explain to
users how things work, you should just be
able to plop this down in front of someone
who understands NFL and they're able to start
getting involved in the app.
In fact, when we do sort of internal reviews
for apps, we find the ones which we like the
best are the ones where rather than everyone
sitting down and everyone sort of nit picking
which pixel should be a different color, we're
all sort of using the app and sort of getting
involved in that.
I'm sure it's a similar experience when you
guys have done games reviews as well.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
>>Reto Meier: That's what you want.
You want it so that people aren't going, "Oh
wait, how did you get to that screen?
What did you do just there?"
It's just like I'm too busy getting engaged
in apps like this there's so much content.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You really need to do some
user testing.
Sit down with somebody, not, and I can't emphasize
this enough, don't sit down with some random
guy who is probably carrying a blackberry
or an Iphone, sit down with someone who's
used to using an Android tablet, you know,
sit down with somebody who's actually your
target market for an Android application and
watch them use it.
If they start swiping their finger across
things that are unswipable and getting frustrated,
that's your first clue.
>>Reto Meier: That's a sign.
In fact, I saw a little tip, so we can slide
here so that's quite nice.
So you can slide between weeks, yeah, 3 week
season.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, the only thing I don't
really like about it is that I think that
it's not obvious enough where you're at.
Like, if you look at most of the view pagers
that we've put out, they have some sort of
indication of where you are, it's either the
little dots like you see on a home screen
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Or it's a tabs or something
like that.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, particularly because it
gives you that indication of where the, you
know, how far along you are and obviously
on this side, it's obvious that there isn't
anything before, well there is, and that's
interesting so.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well it's wrapping around.
>>Reto Meier: It is and particularly so I'm
at pre week 1 and it seems intuitive that
there isn't anything before the first pre
week but there is.
You know, if, you've got the hall of fame
and then we're back to pre week 4 which is,
again, kind of funny how we're doing a wrap
around.
I don't know that you wanna do that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I don't know that I would
have made that choice but whatever.
>>Reto Meier: It's a call.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's valid it's just not,
now here I'll tell you what I'm gonna do.
>>Reto Meier: You gonna clean up the beer?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I'm gonna sacrifice my Android
camp hoody to save your Google lab coat.
>>Reto Meier: My lab coat, It seems like the
lab coat should be the--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: God knows they're not making
any more of them.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: True enough.
So the other thing I'd point out as well is,
I mean, this is a pretty fast device and this
scrolling is not the smoothest.
So there might be something you can do there
to optimize that scroll speed.
Anything which makes the app feel a little
janky really distracts from the user experience
so, you know, when you are designing things,
everything should be as smooth as it possibly
can be.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, and this is, a lot of
times what we see if people are either using
a regular view inefficiently or they're using
a web view to do some of this.
The other thing that's actually, a good tip
for many devices, but not all, which also
happens to line up nicely with our design
guidelines is if you put a little less emphasis
on the gradients here, especially if that's
something the you're adding in after that
fact.
In general, most Android apps and the Android
UI tries to be from simplified and flat, we
don't go for the bubbly look.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And there are devices in the
field that, possibly because of that, are
not actually very good at drawing gradients.
>>Reto Meier: This is true.
I did an experiment, myself, with a compass
app and just, you know, if you do it flat
it renders really quickly, if I put like a
gloss top on top of it, everything slows down.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well, you gotta remember that
anytime you're drawing like a gradient or
a glassy look or anything like that you're
touching the pixels twice as often and, in
many cases, devices are fill bound and that
literally does make it half as fast.
>>Reto Meier: There you go.
So the only other thing we've got here, so
we've got these tabs, these should probably
be actual tabs rather than these weird pseudo
tabs and, again, basically this is the idea
of the text being difficult to pause easily,
being small and not of high contrast is something
you probably wanna look at throughout.
Alright, shall we move on?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yes, let's do so.
>>Reto Meier: Alright, let's have a look.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright, well, I think that
the top rated apps this week by viewers were
actually the--
>>Reto Meier: The football apps.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: The football apps.
>>Reto Meier: The soccer apps?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yes, the football with a round
ball app.
>>Reto Meier: Excellent.
And, in fact, I think, no there's international
rules for football also uses a round ball,
I was gonna say soccer was the only one which
does but it's not quite true.
Alright, let's have a look at FotMob Pro which
I think is one of the top, one of the top
resulting ones.
Trying to go back to the home screen.
So look at this straight away, so this is
a popular app and I would suggest that one
of the main reasons for that is that it's
very useful.
You can get all the soccer scores from basically
whichever league you're watching including
the major league soccer.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh good, let's see if my favorite
team Real Salt Lake is in there.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Apparently not.
>>Reto Meier: Apparently not.
So that's one thing to be concerned of straight
away is that I'm not entirely sure what this
icon represents but clicking it should take
you to something.
I kind of assumed it would be rankings which
makes sense, the very fact that it didn't
appear for the MLS suggests that we're pulling
this down--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: American soccer sucks?
>>Reto Meier: Could be, it could be.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I don't actually mean that,
of course American soccer is the greatest
just like anything American.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: compared to most Australian
things is what I'm saying.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Austrian, of course,
>>Reto Meier: Let's pick on the Australians
we're all asleep right now.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Let's do that.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: It seems reasonable enough.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright, so yeah, I don't
know why that's not showing up but it would
be nice to have something.
>Reto Meier: I think it's just failing to
pull down the data so I think you wanna have
some sort of indication here that it's loading.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Now I'm not a big fan of loading
dialogues or anything like that but there
should be some indication that, "Hey, I'm
trying to pull down data" and if it fails,
saying, "I tried to but for whatever reason
I can't get the information."
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now, I will say that the iconography
in this interface is a little puzzling to
me and you're gonna have to, you know, just
check me on this because, obviously, you know,
I don't actually follow soccer.
>>Reto Meier: Sure.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Maybe this is all totally
old hat to you but I see this thing here and
I think maybe it looks like a list, I don't
know.
And apparently I don't know what I did there.
>>Reto Meier: It's the funky touch targets.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And then apparently this baby
over here that it, to me, it looked like a,
what I would call, soccer ball but that's
exactly
>>Reto Meier: I was gonna say Mickey Mouse.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Apparently that's the top
scores.
>>Reto Meier: Interesting.
So that wouldn't have been obvious to me either.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Really, yeah.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, definitely not.
I would have thought maybe the opposite, like
the top scores would have been a person or
maybe even a person kicking or maybe even
a goal, I don't know, there's a few options
there.
Definitely the iconography needs work.
The idea of having the action bar here is
reasonable but, again, I would go with a more
standard up affordance other than this pseudo
back button.
It's confusing, is it an up button?
Is it a back button?
Is it different from the back button down
at the bottom?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: It's not quite right.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah it's a different, you
know, long time viewers of the show know that
I've never been completely comfortable with
the idea that something pointing to the left
is actually taking me up
>>Reto Meier: That's because this is an affordance,
you see, rather than just a button.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
Exactly and an affordance sounds like something
you live in if you're on a fixed income.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: It really does.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, but the point is that,
that, that space is, as of Honeycomb, reserved
for something that will take you to the previous
point in the view hierarchy of the application
as opposed to the previous screen that you
were on before which is what the system back
button is for.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And the general iconography
for that is that it should have something,
akin to your application icon, in general
that's the, like with a left chevron.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: In this case we've bounced
between what that looks like a back button
and what that looks like a down button.
>>Reto Meier: So I guess this is an attempt
at an overflow menu but on the wrong side.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You think?
>>Reto Meier: Well, we're choosing leagues
so it's kind of settings here at this point.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, but that's the only
thing, right?
It's not like choose leagues and a bunch of
other stuff.
>>Reto Meier: That's true, that's true.
So either way I think you wanna redesign this
into something more like an action bar.
So once you go into the app you've got some
kind of iconography on the top saying what
the app is
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now see, of course, like all
good Android users I'm swiping
>>Reto Meier: You are swiping.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: There's a really good reason
for people to swipe, first, in Android tabs
go on top, as you can see they've already
violated.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And, of course, that makes
one thumb navigation more difficult which
we solved by adding the swipe action.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So even though that might
feel a little bit like an Ambrose Bierce short
story, yeah, I ruined that by not even saying
it right.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
It was almost really good.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, could've been.
You are, you end up having, having to move
your thumb all around, you know, I wanna get
to tomorrow, why can't I get to tomorrow by
swiping?
>>Reto Meier: Swiping to tomorrow.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It seems like the normal thing,
right?
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
So you wanna eliminate these and replace them
with something which is more like a view pager
type set up, straight away.
Move this into an action bar which is on the
top right, get rid of this whole, wow, let's
have a look here, get rid of this whole sort
of down chevron button for choosing leagues.
If it's something you want users to do then
make it an action, if it's something they
should be able to do but don't wanna do very
often then it should probably sit under settings
in the overflow menu, but either way it sort
of looks really weird.
I do recognize it as a glyph that we used
to use in a version of Android at some point.
I vaguely remember back from Cupcake.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You're absolutely right.
Yeah, it was back in the, right, in the Cupcake
and Eclair days back when we didn't have any
designers and we were basically just stealing
our art off the internet.
>>Reto Meier: Just making it up as we went
along.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Pretty much, yeah.
>>Reto Meier: Sad.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: None of that stuff looked
good.
I'm just gonna call that right now.
>>Reto Meier: It really didn't and that's
the beauty of the new stuff is that it really
does.
We've got an incredible design team now which
have really spent a lot of time and effort
thinking about how to make stuff look awesome.
So when you can, take advantage of that.
We see the same thing here as we saw in the
previous app where you've got really small
touch targets and really small text and, again,
like we're looking at the league here, there's
no reason why we can't scroll more if we have
to.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: See this is what I love about
American soccer, by the way.
We got Real Salt Lake which I just can't laugh
enough about.
>>Reto Meier: I can't even bring myself to
even say that.
To me, there has to be a real salt lake.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: What about this CD Chivas
USA, what does that even mean?
Is it boned by the Scotch Company or is there
something called a Chiva of which this is
the plural?
>>Reto Meier: It could be.
They are the Chivas.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Do we have anyone, producer
Alex; do we have anyone on YouTube that knows
the answer to this mystery?
>>Alex Lucas: Nobody's commenting.
>>Reto Meier: If anyone--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I'm sorry, nobody's commenting
at all?
>>Alex Lucas: I'm sorry; nobody's answering
your question.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, okay.
Are they saying stuff about us?
>>Alex Lucas: Not really, no.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Darn.
>>Reto Meier: Is anyone watching?
Hello?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right, yeah.
>>Reto Meier: Is this thing on?
>>Alex Lucas: 41 people are watching.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Nice.
Hey guys.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Also, how do you like my haircut?
Did you notice I got a football haircut?
>>Reto Meier: True story.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And I got a football grin,
too.
[Growls]
>>Reto Meier: Terrifying.
So, yeah, I don't know.
I was trying to figure out what the story
was between, behind CD Chivas earlier today
and I could not, for the life of me, figure
it out.
I don't even know where they play.
I don't know, it's a mystery.
The good news is that, the San Jose Earthquakes
which is, I guess, our local team.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh yeah?
>>Reto Meier: Is leading the Western league.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Awesome.
Yeah, right down there in San Jose.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: By all the used car dealerships
and the check cashing places.
>>Reto Meier: Sweet.
Go Earthquakes.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Paycheck cashing places are
San Jose's second largest business.
>>Reto Meier: Is that right?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: What's it's top business?
Is that safe for work?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think it's Adobe.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, that'll do it, yeah.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: So yeah, there you go and this
is the problem, right?
This is a really good tip, if you find that
your users are exiting the app unexpectedly
then your navigation is broken.
And that's the thing we see most frequently,
where people are using mult-- like you've
got multiple tabs here and so you're jumping
around and you're choosing different things
and then you get back to here and you've pressed
a bunch of buttons.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I want to go back to where
I was.
>>Reto Meier: And you can't quite remember
where you started.
It's like, well I wanna go back to just to
list of things and so I, oh wait, no that
wasn't it.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Although, it's somewhat telling
that I wasn't disappointed in the application
result.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Actually kind of a problem
with sports apps in general, we just had a
talk on Thursday, internally, about some sports
apps and one of the things that I think we
all agreed on is that these are incredibly
challenging because they have to present a
gargantuan amount of information.
I mean, sports, if you think about just how
much information needs to be presented in
all of the different ways you can slice it
and dice it, it is a serious UI challenge.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But that's a great reason
to really think this through and to always
follow Android UI guidelines because the more
you can make it like all other Android apps,
the more you can make consistent UI decisions
that people are gonna expect, the more useable
your apps gonna be and you have to target
useability because you have so much to present
that your app, out of the gate, is already
confusing.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
I mean, anything which is so rich in data
runs that risk.
So it's really, the navigation is probably
your biggest challenge.
Otherwise, the app itself is pretty good.
I mean, you've got your stats, you've got
your scores, you know, all this sort of stuff
really the key here is that this whole app
just kind of needs a navigation refresh and
a UI refresh, something to bring it up to
standard with sort of your ICS type imagery
and layouts.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And I'm just gonna make one
other comment on the, you know, the gradients
here, uh, I don't like that.
I think it's unnecessary and the thing is,
I'm a big fan gradients, I think gradients
can look really incredible and a lot of times
they're much better than a flat screen but
A, they are a little bit tired right now,
they're sort of, they've been done.
>>Reto Meier: They're kind of the lens flare
of the 10's.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
But more than that, gradients look good in
isolation.
When you stack a bunch on top of each other
like this then the eye starts picking up this
pattern and it ends up looking kind of cheesy.
>>Reto Meier: It does, it really does.
If you're not gonna have them sort of, you
know, flowing between different colors like
some sort of old school like jukebox type
scenario then, yeah, it's just gonna be distracting
instead.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
So, in fact, if you look at some of the things
we've done with gradients that I think were
very attractive, we've done things like, take
a list and then put a continuous gradient
all the way down the screen behind it.
That's also fairly expensive.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That's not easy to do and
not all devices can handle it but it looks
fantastic.
Whereas, just stacking these up like this
is
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, it's a waste.
>>Alex Lucas: We have a couple questions on
the screen, actually.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Awesome.
>>Reto Meier: Yes, please.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We'd love to answer some live
questions.
>>Alex Lucas: First, Gerald Smith asks, "Overflow
menu, what does he mean by that?"
If you could describe what, go into a little
more detail about what you're referring to
when you say the overflow menu.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely, so the overflow
menu is the extra menu options that you see
on the action bar when, let's have a look;
we'll fire up, what's a good app for the overflow
menu?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Playstore.
>>Reto Meier: We'll go with the Playstore.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It has an overflow menu.
There you go.
>>Reto Meier: So this is the overflow menu.
Let's try and just get to the standard action
bar if we can.
So here is your typical actions and then everything
just behind that menu bar is the overflow
menu.
So that's where you wanna put things which
users need to get to but they're probably
not the most important things.
So, settings, anything like about, account
information, you know, the sorts of things
they have here are perfect examples of what
you wanna put in the overflow.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly and it's worth mentioning
that the overflow contents can actually change;
now in this case they haven't.
But there are apps where, given a little more
horizontal space, you'd actually see more
action icons over here on the right and then
the overflow menu would have fewer options
in it, Gmail, for instance.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, Gmail is a good one.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: In general, what you wanna
do is think of your action bar as having two
essential pieces, you know, one over the left
you've got the navigation piece and that is
split into your up affordance, in this case,
as we talked about the left chevron, the icon
and usually some indication of where you're
at, in this case it's our search results,
NFL.
And then potentially another navigational
piece like a dropdown.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And then over on the right,
you've got the second major portion of your
action bar which is the action piece and that's
gonna be a set of icons.
If, if you want you can put text here as well,
although that's usually not quite as effective,
it certainly takes up more horizontal space,
and then the overflow.
Now you'll also see, on some devices, on some
apps, a menu that looks like the overflow
menu down here in the corner.
Now we call that the menu button of shame.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And the reason is the only
time you see that menu button is when you
haven't updated your app for an SDK, a target
SDK that's greater than Honeycomb.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
And then most, see this is the proper one
of shame.
So there's two versions of this, there's the
unfortunate version where you've got an app
and you haven't updated it yet so you haven't
figured out how your pre existing menu is
going to work with an action bar.
So that takes a little bit of thought so that's
not good.
But what this is is the real, the real button
of shame.
Which is here and it does absolutely nothing.
So all you do is change your target SDK and
that will go away.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know, the worst thing
is on some devices with custom UIs having
that button there will actually do a bunch
of layout changes.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, wow.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It'll actually put the menu
button over top of the system buttons.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So having that be empty is
extremely unfortunate.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now you're just taken up screen
real estate for absolutely no reason at all.
>>Reto Meier: No.
Nice.
Okay, was there another question, Alex?
>>Alex Lucas: Yeah, Gerald says thanks.
>>Reto Meier: No worries, Gerald.
>>Alex Lucas: The next question is from a
Ross Larson who says, "Can we talk about app
permissions here?
I couldn't install this year's version of
the NFL draft tracker app because my app,
because my device didn't have an onboard GPS."
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, you know, it's, we would
love to talk about app-- in fact we should
do a complete show on app permissions.
>>Reto Meier: I think we will.
I think we'll do an app, an office hours on
permissions.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right, but the problem is
we don't have a show called the Friday rant.
>>Reto Meier: That's true.
The Friday rage.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And we still haven't got permission
to utter pornography and use profanity.
>>Alex Lucas: You're on for an hour a week,
dude, that's the feat.
>>Reto Meier: Utter pornography, that's interesting.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's pornography and profanity
involved with permissions.
>>Reto Meier: And profanity, that would be
quite a show.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Although I'm not 100 percent
that he's asking for permission, there's also
features that come into play here.
>>Reto Meier: I think that's, this is the
issue is that if you request certain permissions,
then for legacy reasons that implies a feature
requirement as well and GPS is one of those
if you request a find or course locator, well,
no, if you request find location then the
system will imply that, well, actually, you're
probably meant to require a GPS as well.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, so, you're absolutely
right, you know, being unable to install that
on a system that doesn't have a GPS is an
indication that the app has done something
that we consider to be sketchy.
First, they haven't made it so you can have
an optional permission or an optional feature
but, more importantly, they're requiring find
location which is unusual and almost always
indicates that they have an ad network that's
attempting to track you at an inappropriate
level.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, this is true.
I mean, obviously it's gonna depend on the
app and you're gonna have to figure out based
on, you know, what they offer if that makes
sense and I suspect if it's anything that's
displaying video, they may be using the find
location to figure out where you are to make
sure they have the rights to show you that
video in that location.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Course location would do that
as well, right?
>>Reto Meier: It should be at the very least
city, you know, accurate to a city level which
definitely should be sufficient for anything
like rights management.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: The thing too is if you are
doing that then that's, that's totally insecure
because you're just trusting the client to
say where it's at, that could be hijacked
so easily.
So I think most video services would be--
>>Reto Meier: A little more clever.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: In general, they'll do IP
filtering which is easy to spoof as well but
more costly.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
Okay, so, for developers out there wondering
how you can get around this, you can simply
specify a user's feature and specify location
as a required false which effectively makes
it optional.
Then, within your app you'll need to check
to see whether or not there is a GPS or some
form of location sensing hardware available
before you make those location update requests.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And consider that, not just
for GPS, but for other things that you may
or may not find.
For instance, a back facing camera.
>>Reto Meier: That's a good one, yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, if you ask for a camera,
well, several devices, and the most important
one to us being the Nexus 7, do not have rear
facing cameras and the rear facing camera
is what you get if you say you need a camera.
I think that's a little confusing, honestly.
>>Reto Meier: It can be but it's one of those
legacy type deals where, you know, when we
put in the user's feature and permission for
a camera, it was only rear facing camera.
So, yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: In general, I think the rule
of thumb is don't ask for a feature or permission
unless you're app depends on it.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: If that's what your app is
all about, if all your app does is take photos,
then by all means say that a camera is required.
But, if your app has any other functionality,
for instance, viewing sets of photos or applying
filter effects to your photos, then don't
require a camera because people might want
to do that with a set that they've uploaded
to Google Plus or that things that they've
downloaded from their camera or whatever.
>>Reto Meier: Cause keep in mind, for those
users, Nexus 7 users aren't going to be outraged
to find out they can't take photos with your
photo taking app given that they have a device
without a camera.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: They'll figure that out.
>>Reto Meier: They'll, exactly, they'll know
what to expect.
So you wanna give them as much as they can
so they can still do, you know, the other
things.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, now, I'm just gonna
say we've covered a grand total of 2 apps.
>>Reto Meier: We've done well.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And engineer Daniel is over
there going like this.
>>Reto Meier: Going, I'm gonna have no time
to set up this next show.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Because engineer Daniel thinks
that he is the producer of the show.
But--
>>Reto Meier: That's because engineer, because
engineer Daniel is gonna be on the next show,
right?
So he just doesn't wanna have his time in
the sun curtailed by us going over.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That's true.
That is very true.
>>Reto Meier: We're on to you, Daniel.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: The truth is, I think we've
looked at what most of the apps in this category
do, you know, pretty deeply.
Feature wise and in terms of the mistake that
we've seen people make, so why don't we just
really quickly, do a lightening round, we
have DFB.
>>Reto Meier: I think all the sort of sports
updates, news and scores I think are all gonna
be pretty much along the same lines.
Did you wanna have; did you wanna spend a
couple of minutes looking at any of the fantasy
football apps?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think we better not.
I think, we talked, we looked at the one app
that had some things we didn't like about
it and I think it'd be fair to look at some
of these other apps because I think they do
things better or worse.
For instance, DFB, despite the fact that it's
completely in German, I found myself liking
it a lot.
>>Reto Meier: It's just got a much more conventional
style here.
We've got a normal action bar with a normal
layout, navigation on the left, swipable view
pager, it looks really nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it makes me; it makes
me feel like I'm reading a sports page.
>>Reto Meier: Yes.
This is a key and this is, again, something
we discussed internally, It's like, the thing
about any sports news information is that
imagery is really important to that and so
we watch sports for the imagery it contains
and so you wanna have something which is like
reading a magazine, lots of images, lots of
video, lots of full bleed content so that
you sort of, swiping through looking at stuff
and getting seen what catches your eye, that's
really powerful.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: In fact, the only thing that
I would love to see is for these pictures
here to actually be larger.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now we've complained some
about apps that put text over images when
that's inappropriate especially for social
apps, for instance, that have images that
are user created, you never know exactly what
you're gonna get.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: but in this case you do and
it's almost always appropriate to bleed this
through just the way they've done here.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
The way that you've got it here on the title,
if it was just all of the items in that list
done the same way, I think that would look
fantastic.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now do you see?
It just synced and the sync icon rotated.
>>Reto Meier: Automatically.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Beautiful.
>>Reto Meier: Very nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Very nice.
I don't know what this is.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Nothing good.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Apparently it's the crash
button.
>>Reto Meier: It's the, yeah, the quick exit
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But you can see they've done
exactly what we ask in action bar.
>>Reto Meier: Perfect.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Which means I know exactly
how to use this application.
I know that I'm gonna see actions up here,
I know if I wanna share it's gonna be there,
I'm guessing this is gonna make the text bigger
or smaller, that's nice.
>>Reto Meier: That makes sense.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: If I wanna save this for later
what am I gonna do?
>>Reto Meier: You're gonna hit the star, right?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
Star button.
>>Reto Meier: It's kind of the wrong color
but that's okay and it probably wants to be
offset a little bit so it doesn't tip the
edges.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's probably one of those
European star buttons.
>>Reto Meier: But, you know, I'm nit picking
at this point.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Everything's different over
there.
>>Reto Meier: The other thing I'd also, you've
got some crashing issues.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah and the up affordance
is a little different.
>>Reto Meier: It's a little sketchy, yeah.
It's not quite right.
The other thing I'd point out as well is we
have this mixture of icon style.
So, you can see here that we're presumably
using the system built in icons for refresh
and share but the ones that these guys have
built themselves are slightly different colors.
I don't know if this comes across on the video
but these are gray and the custom ones here
are white.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's really tough to get right.
>>Reto Meier: It is hard to get right.
But it's worth doing and it's also worth doing
them all yourself so rather than depending
on the system to provide some, use the system
provided ones, I believe they're available
for download from developer.Android.com/design
these days and so you, this way you don't
have to worry about the system changing any
of them on a different implementation.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Although hopefully that won't
happen nearly as much anymore.
>>Reto Meier: Indeed, indeed.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Particularly with different
manufacturers putting skins on their devices,
you never know for certain, what icons they're
gonna provide.
So by providing them yourself you have that
security.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, and just really quickly,
I think the last thing we were gonna look
at was the live score thing.
See, loading countries, right there, my American
sensibility is--
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, it's out the window.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: See, quick set up should be
done automatically.
So, again, you don't wanna have to go through
and do all this the first time, you just wanna
jump straight in to whatever you think is
the most obvious.
Now, whether that's choosing countries based
on the current location using course location
to get an idea or just picking the countries
which most people use, all those sorts of
things are gonna provide a better experience
if you can get started straight away.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, absolutely.
So of course I'm gonna follow Real Salt Lake.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, so, in general, this
has some good stuff going for it.
It's got the, it's obviously syncing or something
but it's showing me something while it's syncing.
>>Reto Meier: You get done straight away and
that's really important.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah and it's a really pretty,
I love the color.
>>Reto Meier: It's really nice.
Again, the text is really, really small.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's a little small.
>>Reto Meier: I think this is a common problem
for people who are going, "We have so much
data, how do we display it all at once?"
Well, you don't have to display it at once.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Better to have fewer things
on screen and let people do a flick scroll
or a left, right scroll.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: The very last thing I wanna
mention is although this looks like an action
bar, it's not.
It doesn't act the way an action bar does,
it doesn't have an up affordance, it doesn't
have actions on the right, it's got navigation
here but one of the navigation things is more
which does not include, it's not just navigation.
>>Reto Meier: And, in fact, this is really,
most of this stuff should belong in the overflow
menu.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
So, you might wanna think about actually just
moving to a standard Android action bar or
if that just doesn't suit your sensibility
maybe moving to a drawer pattern or something
like that.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And that is definitely all
the time we have but we've been able to cover
all the apps so I'm really pleased about that.
Thanks very much to our engineer Daniel Pham
and our producer Alex Lucas and I think it's
about time to sign off.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
I think we'll sign out.
So we're gonna have, engineer Daniel is gonna
come in front of the camera and join you,
I think, this, this week, Ian.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yes.
>>Reto Meier: We're gonna have a look at some
NFL games.
That should be exciting and I'm not sure what
we've got scheduled for next week in terms
of the app clinic.
Do we know for certain?
>>Daniel Pham: We actually haven't decided
yet but you made a great post on G Plus asking
for topics so I think we should take a look
at that and, you know, choose based on what
people wanna see.
>>Reto Meier: Perfect.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That was your personal G Plus,
right?
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, it was.
So we're gonna go through that list and see
what you guys want us to have a look at and
we'll update the moderator page with the details
for that and look for your suggestions over
the, well, what is for us here in the US at
least, a long weekend.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Excellent.
>>Reto Meier: So, until then, enjoy the weekend
and hopefully stayed tuned for the Friday
games review.
Goodbye.